there were renewed calls this week for
better computer security after former
Secretary of State Colin Powell Z mails
were hacked cyber thieves warned that no
computer system is safe but one low tech
solution is being practiced by the head
of the FBI and the founder of Facebook
Jeff Pegues has the story the security
officials say hackers believe every
system can be broken into even the web
camera on your computer I could break
into your phone I could break into your
tablet Tyler Cohen would is a cyber
security expert with inspired eLearning
if you're not using it turn it off you
also want to make sure that you are not
using unsecured wireless access because
anyone else that's on that same wireless
network has the ability to sniff the
traffic and potentially get into your
computer that way just this week FBI
director James Comey raised a few
eyebrows when he suggested that you put
a piece of tape over the web camera to
prevent someone from turning it into a
surveillance tool you go in any
government office we all have our little
camera things that sit on top of the
screen they'll have a little lid that
closes down on them Facebook founder
Mark Zuckerberg not only puts tape over
the camera but the microphone too
tape is not enough the experts say that
you want to run virus scans as well if
someone has access to the point where
they are controlling your camera and
they have full access to everything on
your computer for CBS this morning
Saturday I'm Jeff Pegues Washington